je vous ai dit que michelle nichols
avait été importante pour inspirer les
gens de couleur à poursuivre leur rêve
d' espaces mais elle est loin d'être
resté une simple inspira trichet l'a
directement collaboré avec la nasa pour
favoriser l'embauché de minorités et
elle a notamment recruté sally ride est
la première femme astronaute américaine
et le colonel guillaume blot ford le
premier astronaute afro américains oas 7
au 9 mai dernier
mais c'est pas fini parce qu'elle ne se
contente pas de changer des choses dans
l'espace elle est aussi connue pour le
tout premier baiser interracial de
l'histoire de la télévision alors dans
l'épisode des personnages sont sous le
contrôle mental delmi extraterrestre
mais ça n'en reste pas moins une petite
révolution la diffusion date de 1968
soit à peine 4 ans après la fin de sa
délégation et seulement un an après la
légalisation totale des mariages métissé
aux états unis d'ailleurs pour la petite
anecdote les producteurs avaient demandé
à ce que soit tourner une version de
l'épisode sans le baiser juste au cas où
mais les deux acteurs ont fait exprès de
jouer le plus mal possible pour que
toutes les prix soit raté et qu'ils
soient obligés de garder le baiser dans
le montage final et ça c'est ce que
j'appelle être badass